in the last video you and I looked at
this demo here where we shine linearly
polarized light through a tube full of
sugar water and we saw how it rather
mysteriously results in these colored
diagonal Stripes there I walked through
the general outline for an explanation
keeping track of what questions still
need to be answered namely why does
sugar water twist the polarization
direction of light why does that
twisting rate depend on the color of the
light and why even if you understand
that this twist is happening would you
see any evidence of it when viewing the
tube from the side with no additional
polarizing filters here I'd like to
begin with the very fundamental idea of
what light is and show how the answers
to these questions can emerge from an
extremely minimal set of
assumptions in some sense the
fundamental question of electricity and
magnetism is how the position and motion
of one charged particle influences that
of another for example one of the first
things you learn say in a High School
physics class is that charges with the
same sign tend to repel each other and
the strength of this Force depends a lot
on the distance between them if your
charges are close that repulsive force
is very strong but it decays very
rapidly as these particles go away from
each other specifically here's how you
might see this written down as an
equation known as kum's law the force is
proportional to the charge of both of
the particles where it's common to use
the letter Q There are some constants in
there which for our purposes we can just
think of as one big proportionality
constant and the important fact is that
you've got this 1 / R 2 term where R is
the distance between them so for example
if the distance between them increases
by a factor of three the force that
they're applying to each other goes down
by a factor of nine another way you
might see a law like this written down
is to focus on just one charged particle
and then say for every point in space if
there was a second charge there what
force would this first charge be app
applying to that second
one and instead of describing a force
per se you might see this written
describing what's known as the electric
field which is just a way of saying what
force would be applied to a unit charge
and in this context the word field means
there's a value associated with every
single point in space so the way I have
it written here it depends on a little
Vector R which would be the vector from
our charge to a given point in space and
the direction of this field at all
points is in the same direction as
R I bring up kum's law to emphasize that
it's not the full story there are other
ways that charges influence each other
for example here's a phenomenon that
this law alone could not explain if you
wiggle one charge up and down then after
a little bit of a delay a second charge
some distance to its right will be
induced to wiggle up and down as well we
can write down a second law which you
might think of as a correction term to
be added to kul's law that describes
what's going on here suppose at some
point in time t0 that first charge is
accelerating then I'll let time play
forward but leave on the screen a kind
of ghost of that particle indicating
where it was and how it was accelerating
at this time t0 after a certain delay
this causes a force on the second charge
and the equation describing this Force
looks something like this so again it's
proportional to the charge of both of
the particles and once more a common way
to write it involves this pile of
constants that you don't really need to
worry about the important factor I want
you to notice is how the force also
depends on the distance between the
particles but instead of decaying in
proportion to R 2 it only decays in
proportion to R so over long distances
this is the force that dominates and
coom's law is negligible and then
finally it depends on the acceleration
of that first particle but it's not the
acceleration of that particle at the
current time it's whatever that
acceleration was at some time in the
past
how far in the past depends on the
distance between the particles and the
speed of light denoted with C the way to
think about it is that any form of
influence can't propagate any faster
than this speed C in fact a more
accurate description of kum's law would
also involve a delay term like this
again the intuitive way to read this
equation is that wiggling a charge in
one location after some delay causes a
wiggle to a second charge in another
location and actually the way I have it
written right now is a little bit wrong
instead of the acceleration vector here
I should really be writing something
like a per indicating the component of
that acceleration vector which is
perpendicular to the line drawn between
the two charges in other words when you
wiggle that first charge the direction
that the second charge Wiggles is always
perpendicular to the line between them
and the amount that it Wiggles gets
weaker and weaker when that line between
them is more lined up with the initial
acceleration as before this is something
you might see written down in a way that
describes a component of the electric
field caused by just one charge again
that means what force would be applied
to a second charge at all possible
different points in
space this component of the field is
only ever nonzero when our first charge
is moving somehow when it has an
acceleration vector on it and because of
this delay term the effects on this
field tend to radiate away from the
charge this is why I'm writing it down
with the subscript rad this is the
component of the electric field F that
will radiate away from a given charge
for instance when the charge is
oscillating up and down you get these
propagating waves and for many of the
vector Fields I'll be showing the
intensity of the field is Illustrated
with the opacity of each little Vector
this radiating influence is light or
more generally electromagnetic radiation
including things like radio waves and
x-rays and all that good
stuff as a side note you sometimes see
this propagation described a very
different way that puts the fields front
and Center using what are known as
Maxwell's equations for our purposes I
want to focus just on this one law and
show just how far it can take us when it
comes to intuitions for
light for the animations I'm about to
show all I've really done is encoded in
this one law which tells us what should
this component of the electric field be
at every point in space as determined by
the history of accelerations of a
particular charge for example if I set
that charge oscillating up and down in
the Z Direction and illustrate this
component of the electric field
everywhere on the XY plane you see these
circular propagations of equal strength
in all
directions it's a little easier to think
about if we focus on just one axis like
the
x-axis and at first when I made this
animation I assumed that there was some
kind of bug cuz near the charge it just
looks crooked and wrong but when you
think about it this is actually what you
should expect because remember each one
of these vectors is supposed to be
perpendicular to the line drawn between
that point and where the charge was at
some point in the
past at points that are far enough away
from the charge which is where this
component of the field is what dominates
anyway the wiggling in the field is
essentially parallel to the wiggling in
the charge which is why when we think
about light waves we're safe to think
about the wiggling direction as being
perpendicular to the propagation
Direction like I said this propagation
for just one charge is equally strong in
all of the directions perpendicular to
its wiggling and really I should
emphasize that the propagation does
happen in all directions of
threedimensional
space it's maybe a little busy to try to
illustrate the full three-dimensional
Vector field on screen like this so it's
clarifying if we just focus on say the
XZ plane notice how the waves here are
strongest in the X Direction but it
still does propagate in all other
directions it's just that that
propagation gets weaker in directions
that are more aligned with the original
wiggling at the extreme the only place
where there's no propagation is in the
z-axis because our law has this 1 / r in
it the strength of the wave caused by
just one particle does Decay as you go
farther away in proportion to 1 / R but
notice what happens if I take a whole
row of charges say oriented along the Y
AIS and I have them all start wiggling
up and down in the Z Direction and I
illustrate the combined effects that all
of them have on this component of the
electric field
the effects of all these charges
interfere
wave propagations we were illustrating
earlier if at some distance away you
have a large number of charges
oscillating in sync with each other like
this one thing that's worth emphasizing
when you see light Illustrated with a
sine wave like this is that even though
that wave is being drawn in two or three
dimensions it's only describing the
electric field along a one-dimensional
line namely the base of all those
vectors it's just that to draw the
vectors you have to venture off of that
line great so one of the last important
things to highlight before we get back
to the sugar water is polarization in
everything I've been showing the driving
charge is just oscillating along a
single Direction like the z-axis and
this causes linearly polarized light but
it doesn't have to happen like that for
example if I set the charge rotating in
a little circle along the YZ plane
meaning its acceleration vector is also
rotating in a little circle notice what
the field looks like this is known aptly
enough as circularly polarized light
honestly it's easiest to think about for
just one point of the electric field
what it means for light to be circularly
polarized is that at that point the
electric field Vector is just rotating
in a circle people often find circular
polarization a little confusing and I
suspect part of the reason for that is
that it's hard to illustrate with the
static diagram but also it's a little
confusing when you try to think about
the full electric field for example
here's what the field looks like on the
XY plane when I set that little charge
rotating in a circle
it's certainly very beautiful I could
look at this all day but you can
understand why it might feel a little
confusing the very last thing I'll
mention is that while everything here is
a classical description of light the
important points still hold up in
quantum mechanics you still have
propagating waves there's still
polarization that can be either linear
or circular the main difference with
quantum mechanics is that the energy in
this wave doesn't scale up and down
continuously like you might expect it
comes in discreet Little Steps I have
another video that goes into more detail
but for our purposes thinking about it
classically is fine part of the reason I
wanted to go through that is because
frankly it's just very fun to animate
and I like an excuse for a fundamental
lesson but now let's turn back to our
demo and see how we can build up an
intuition for some of our key questions
starting from this very basic premise
that shaking a charge in one location
causes a shake to another charge a
little bit later and let's start by
actually skipping ahead to question
number three why do we see the diagonal
stripes
[Music]
to think about this you need to imagine
an observer to the side of the tube and
then for a particular Pure Color say red
if the observer looks in the tube and
sees that color it's because light of
that color has bounced off something at
that point in the tube and then
propagated towards the eye of the
Observer sometimes when people talk
about light bouncing off of things the
implied mental image is something like a
projectile ricocheting off of some
object heading off in some random
Direction but the better mental image to
hold in your mind is that when the
propagating light waves caused by some
wiggling charge reach some second charge
causing it to wiggle that secondary
wiggle results in its own propagation
and for the animation on screen that
propagation goes back to the first
charge which itself causes a propagation
towards the second and this is what it
looks like in a very simplified
situation for light to bounce back and
forth between two charges if you have
some concentrated beam of polarized
light interacting with some charge
causing it to wiggle up and down then
these resulting second order
propagations are most strong in the
directions perpendicular to the
direction of polarization in some sense
you could think of light as bouncing off
of that charge but the important point
is that it doesn't bounce in all
directions equally it's strongest
perpendicular to the wiggle Direction
but gets weaker in all of the other
directions so think about our setup and
for a particular frequency of light How
likely it is that an observer looking at
a particular point in the tube will see
that light again the key Phenomenon with
sugar water which we have yet to explain
is that the polarization direction is
slowly getting twisted as it goes down
the tube so suppose The Observer was
looking at a point like this one where
the polarization Direction happens to be
straight up and down then the second
order propagations resulting from
wiggling charges at that point are most
strong along the plane where the
Observer is so the amount of red that
they see at that point would look
Stronger by contrast if they were
looking at a different point in the tube
like this one where the wiggling
direction is closer to being parallel to
the line of sight then the direction
where the scattering is strongest is not
at all aligned with the Observer and the
amount of red they see is only going to
be very
weak and looking at our actual physical
setup if we first pass the light through
a filter showing only the red we see
exactly this effect in action as you
scan your eyes along the tube the
intensity of red that you you see goes
from being high to being low where it's
almost black back to being high
again as an analogy imagine there was a
ribbon going down the tube always
aligned with the polarization direction
for this color then putting yourself in
the shoes of the Observer when you look
at points where the ribbon appears very
thin you're going to see very little red
light whereas if you scan your eyes over
to points where the ribbon appears
thicker you're going to see more red
light one thing that's nice about this
is that if we try it for various
different colors you can actually see
how the twisting rates are different for
each one of the colors notice with red
light the distance between where it
appears brightest and where it appears
darkest is relatively long whereas if
you look down the colors of the rainbow
that distance between the brightest
point and the darkest Point gets lower
and
lower so what you're seeing in effect is
how red light twists slowly whereas
light waves with higher frequencies get
twisted more
aggressively
but still you might wonder why the
boundaries between light and dark points
appear diagonal why is it that in
addition to having variation as you scan
your eyes from left to right there's
also variation as you scan your eyes
from the top of the tube to the bottom
this has less to do with what's going on
in the tube and more to do with a matter
of perspective take a moment to think
about many different parallel beams of
light ranging from the top of the tube
to the bottom at the beginning all of
these light waves are wiggling up and
down and as you pass through the tube
and the effects of the sugar water
somehow twists these directions because
they're all passing through the same
amount of sugar they're getting twisted
by the same amounts so at all points the
polarization of these waves are parallel
to each other if you're the Observer and
you look at the topmost point here its
wiggling direction is essentially
parallel to the line of sight so the
light scattering from that point is
basically not going to reach your eyes
at all it should appear black but if you
scan your eyes down the tube the angle
between the line of sight and the
wiggling Direction changes and so there
will be at least some component of red
light scattering towards the eye so as
you scan your eyes from top to bottom
the amount of a particular color you see
might vary say from dark to
light the full demo that has white light
is basically a combination of all these
Pure Color patterns that go from light
to dark to light with diagonal
boundaries between the intense points
and the weak points hence why you see
diagonal boundaries between the colors
in inside the
tube and now at last let's turn to the
heart of the matter and try to explain
why interactions with sugar would make
Light twist like this in the first place
it's related to the idea that light
seems to slow down as it passes through
a given medium for example if you look
at the crests of a light wave as it goes
into water the crests through the water
are traveling about 1.33 times slower
than the crests of that wave would
travel in a vacuum this number is What's
called the index of refraction for water
in a bit what I'd like to show is how
this index of refraction can be
explained by analyzing how the initial
light wave shakes all the charges in the
material and how the resulting second
order propagations superimpose with that
original light wave for right now I'll
just say that the interactions with each
layer of the material ends up having the
effect of slightly shifting back the
phase of the wave and on the whole this
gives the overall appearance that that
wave moves slower as it passes through
the material
[Music]
skipping ahead to what's going on with
sugar the relevant property of sucrose
here is that it's what's called a chyal
molecule meaning it's fundamentally
different from its Mirror Image you
could never reorient it in space to
become identical to its Mirror Image
it's like a left hand or a right hand or
another much simpler example of a chyal
shape is a spiral if I take this
right-handed spiral then its mirror
image is a left-handed spiral and no
matter how you try to rotate and
reorient that first one it'll never
become identical to the
second what's going on then is that the
presence of a chyro molecule in the
water like this introduces an asymmetry
when it comes to interactions with light
specifically circularly polarized light
it turns out that the amount this chairo
molecule slows down say left-handed
circularly polarized light is different
from the amount that it slows down
right-handed circularly polarized light
effectively there's not one index of
refraction but
two now you might say that seems
irrelevant to our setup since we are
very deliberately shining in linearly
polarized light there is no circularly
polarized light but actually there's a
sense in which linearly polarized light
is equal parts left-handed and
right-handed circularly polarized
light here Focus your attention on just
one vector in this wave wiggling
straight up and down which is to say
polarized in the Z
Direction notice how it's possible to
express this vector as a sum of two
rotating vectors one of them rotating at
a constant rate counterclockwise and the
other one rotating
clockwise adding them together tip to
tail results in a vector oscillating on
a
line in this case it's a vertical line
but that direction can change based on
the phase of the two vectors we're
adding together here let me throw up a
couple labels to keep track of how much
each one of those two vectors has
rotated in total and then every now and
then I'm going to slow down that first
Vector a little bit and I want you to
notice what happens to their
sum well every time I slow it down
effectively knocking back its phase a
little bit it causes the linearly
wiggling sum to wiggle in a slightly
different
direction so if the circularly polarized
light wave represented by that left
Vector gets slowed down a little bit
every time it runs across a sugar
molecule or at least slowed down more
than its oppositely rotating counter
part wood the effect on the sum is to
slowly rotate the direction of linear
polarization and hence as you look at
slices further and further down the tube
the polarization direction does indeed
get twisted the way we were describing
earlier representing how the composite
effects with many many many different
sugar molecules are slightly different
for left-handed light than they are for
right-handed light as a nice way to test
whether you understood everything up to
this point see if just by looking at the
direction of the diagonal slices on our
tube you can deduce which kind of light
the sugar is slowing down more
left-handed light or right-handed
light I'll call this a partial answer to
our question number one because it still
leaves us wondering why there's an index
of refraction in the first place and how
exactly it might depend on the
polarization of the light not just the
material it's passing through also like
I said at the start a robust enough
intuition here should also answer for us
why the strength of this effect would
depend on the frequency of the light
at this point I think we've covered
quite enough for one video so I'll pull
out a discussion covering the origins of
the index of refraction to a separate
[Music]
video